to mississippi now where the governor
tate reeves has declared a state of
emergency amid concerns that flooding
could inundate part of the state's
largest city people in jackson
mississippi are being urged to evacuate
at this hour as dangerously high river
rivers threaten to flood streets and
homes carter evans is tracking the
extreme weather there in mississippi and
other states
if you are capable of getting out now
get out now get out as soon as possible
urgent warnings as the pearl river near
jackson mississippi begins to overflow
persistent rain this past week caused
the river to rise and now at least 100
homes could face flooding we went
through the flood in 2020
never thought it'd happen this quick
anitra and mickey holder lost their home
in the last major flood two years ago
and just finished rebuilding now they're
worried they'll have to do it all over
again our whole home was flooded out we
had to have our whole house
gutted inside out
in minnesota gusts up to 85 miles per
hour sent tree branches flying across
streets and into buildings officials
near the twin cities say four tornadoes
briefly touched down over the weekend
causing a trail of destruction
in the west a rum creek fire near
medford oregon nearly doubled in size
yesterday growing to more than 10
thousand acres the fires burning in a
remote area making it tough for
firefighters to gain control steep
terrain tall timber heavy fuels the
river there's a lot going on crews are
relying heavily on air support to fight
the flames which have already destroyed
several structures and forced hundreds
to evacuate officials say 25-year-old
firefighter logan taylor died while
battling the blaze after being struck by
a falling tree for cbs morning's carter
evans los angeles